well hi friends hi
we've got we've got big news to discuss
big news to discuss
so we talked a couple weeks ago
thought maybe something was happening
and it totally was right you knew in
that moment that you were having a baby
and didn't tell me
rice you do you knew he knew something
yeah bryce knew something was up yes we
knew for my 30th birthday
i had the best gift given to me
my body also helped out too um i am
pregnant
[Applause]
during her pregnancy more so than like
let's say somebody else's pregnancy
where you know you're just excited and
you can't wait
i didn't have that she had she had like
three times where she was bleeding and
we
rushed to the emergency room because we
were worried and obviously
thought that maybe the worst that might
have come lala was
on bed rest for about six weeks right
yeah yeah wow scary start but now
you're now happy but now we're in the
happy times
yeah can you walk me through how you
found out and then how you broke the
news to randall that you were uh
pregnant
yeah we we were in north carolina
and we had where were we at at randall's
favorite
place ever which is his childhood camp
camp highlander
he's such a dream we had just been in
florida
and my mom kept saying to me i feel like
you're pregnant because i
was just like there was just something
that felt different
about me i guess so while he was out one
day
it was just myself and riley at home and
i was like should i take this test ride
and she was like if it's for your health
you got to take it so
i took the test and i looked at her and
was like
right do you know what this means
this means that lala's gonna have a baby
and she like
sprung up she's like we gotta tell my
dad right now
i'm gonna say lala and the thingy
that's what you're gonna do yeah i'm
gonna say hang the thingy cause they
don't know what it is
i wish i could say that it was like this
big elaborate thing that i did for him
to tell him that he was gonna be
a dad to my child our
child it's ours first i was like
you did it without me but then i was
like couldn't believe we were having a
baby
very excited and then her mom came and
my old
came and then everybody found out so
your mom was there what was your mom's
reaction
other than crying sobbing
you know this will be my mom's you know
first grandbaby from
a biological child so i think and now
that it's a girl you know we're just
we're already planning like girl trips
and how we're gonna dress her and we're
just so excited we're so corny
i loved you sharing on the podcast that
you kind of grew up in this little pod
of
moms and daughters and you get to have
that the pregnancy pact
was real it was real was it really real
or was it just like kismet that it all
happened no it was
very much and it sounds so cheesy but i
have always been hell-bent on having my
children grow up the way that i did and
so
you know when stasi first found out that
she
was pregnant i'm talking to her and she
she smiles and says
i'm pregnant like y'all need to get it
poppin
so i called random i was like we it
doesn't matter when the
wedding is happening we are yanking
iud out because i don't want to go make
new friends so that my
my kid has friends i would like my
friends to have kids so that mike
has you know friends to play with that
i've made for them already so stasi
stasi breaks the news i'm having a baby
and your first
thought is i gotta pull the iud out
well because we were planning randall
and i to
i had a doctor's appointment literally a
week before our wedding
because i was ready like you know i'm i
just turned
30 i'm ready to be a mom so that was
already
in play and then you know i just decided
who needs a wedding before a baby it's
20 20 like
whatever there there are no rules there
are really no rules after 2020.
so we know at least two girls on the way
you and stassi
at the gender reveal you s you know pink
comes down and you turn to stassi and
you said i hope they do better in life
than us
seriously why did you jump to that right
away
you know i think any time
you take on a role like this you know
everything is changing for me
i have a huge responsibility now and
you always want you know you're the
person that
is going to be your baby to do better
than you did and my
goal with this baby is just to be
a safe place and a supportive mama just
like i grew up with you know it's a
judgment-free zone
i was going to ask you what kind of mom
do you want to be what
kind of parent do you want to be oh i
want to be the type of mom
that i guess i grew up with my mom was
very much my best friend
no conversation is off limits we can
talk about it all
what do you think your dad would think
about you becoming a mom
so funny that you bring that up because
the reason i'm late is i
was driving and i just broke down
sorry
it's okay baby um i had a tough day
crying about the fact that
he's not here and you would think after
you know
over two years i would be able to think
about him and not
sob i'm not quite there yet
the second i found out i was pregnant
and saw that like
the first thing that came to my mind was
like wow
you know like my dad would be so excited
about this
so he'll be very missed but i know he's
he's got my back up there he's gonna
make sure i'm okay
i just want to say since her father has
passed
the last two years of her life clearly
at least i believe she has an angel
guardian angel because
her life in the last few years is
night and day and it does feel like
having now
talked to you for like the last four
years that the last two
everything did fall into place so i do
think your dad is
he's up there whispering in somebody's
ear i'll give this to my girl make this
happen for my girl
i think so too last time we talked this
is one of the hints i had that maybe
something was happening you said
megan fox had offered up her services to
be your doula so
is she the doula do we have a birth plan
in place already
the can i i thought i would be the type
of person where the second i found out i
was pregnant i would be like
googling things and ordering things and
honestly
i i should be a better mom to be i
haven't looked anything up the only
thing i know is my baby is the size of a
lime today
you got to see the first sonogram and
all that
it seemed you shared a little bit of
that what was it like to see the baby
for the first time
i was i don't think i've ever i didn't
think
i could be so in love with something
that i've never met before
like i just stare at it and i'm like
it's gonna be a little mini
la la and rand like this is the more
lollipop
because it's a girl yeah but i just like
i
look i have you should see my fridge
every time i get a new one i have been
plastered
all over my fridge and i just stare at
her and like you're the most
beautiful little alien i've ever seen
so parenting motherhood it changes
everything
that's what i hear from everybody it
changes everything do you think becoming
a mom will change
how you feel about or how you operate
when it comes to
reality tv yes because i
it already has changed me as a person
you know i
right now i'm in a very like delicate
space and i'm very protective and i just
kind of want to incubate right now
and take my time to mentally and
emotionally prepare i want to make sure
that
my baby is you know living in a healthy
space
in my tummy until she arrives
and once she gets here i think
things will be different i i don't want
her to have a mom that's popping off
left and right and you know goes crazy
at the flip of a dime
no there's a lot yeah you know there's a
lot of things that
that are going to change now i'm not
saying i you know
won't clap back because that's just in
my dna
but yeah i think i'm going to be much
more delicate
i hope i mean she just she's
very maternal and i think that with now
that she has this
baby growing inside her she's very very
protective and
very you know i can already see a change
on that side you know but she's still
lala and nobody's
gonna tell lala what's up stasi did her
big interview
and i thought it was interesting that
she said even if she were given the
chance to come back to vanderpump rules
she probably wouldn't because motherhood
has made her really re-evaluate stuff so
do you want to continue to do vanderpump
rules i know the future of the show is
still up in the air but
the future of the show is very much up
in the air
but i think i i need to see what
next season would entail you know
because
i need to make sure that it's a healthy
space for me i
i don't get to think just about what's
good for lala
and what she how she would react to
certain things you know
i'm i'm going to be a mother i i don't
have
just these kids that are someone else's
kids watching me now i have my own child
looking up to me
so i it would have to it would have to
be the right situation
you know it's a different zone now where
there's
brittany and i are becoming moms i just
don't see me walking into sir clapping
back at danica
for serving me the wrong meal you know
it's a lot is going to change it sounds
like
where you're sitting now you're going to
wait till there's a go
talk to the people who are in charge to
figure out what's the game plan here
what's the show going to look like
moving forward and make your decision
then
yes exactly that's a very good one
that's the game plan
which is so crazy because for me i i
never
look at things and think like i'm just
gonna sit back and take a beat yeah
i'm a reactor yeah so
this new uh girl inside of me
my baby is has changed me in the sense
where if i get an
email i don't like i take a beat if i
think something may not fit i take a
beat so
that's changed too wow
already lots of change for you i'm so
i'm so grown bryce on the podcast too
you guys started throwing around names
and randall
where are you serious with the name
cloud is cloud really a name you guys
are considering
great name i think it's original he left
cloud and spotlight for real i was like
bro spotlight i went a little off
cloud is a good deal for the rest of
this kid's life
the first day of school teachers taking
attendance cloud emmett are you here
cloud class we're just
setting her up to be a
[Laughter]
i'm gonna stoner honest whether lala
likes or not lala and i
have already agreed on a name but the
one that she loved the most after she
had gone through an extensive list
i didn't even flinch i was like money in
the bank that's it let's do it
so her name is money in the bank
and when she's ready she'll tell
[Music]
everybody
you